hey guys Mary here at PAX 2016 along
with Tony hey and at the devolver
digital booth while you're walking
around you also saw another sequel
called sometimes always monsters which
is the sequel to always sometimes
monsters yes what's up with their SEO ok
so always sometimes monsters what's a
game about starting with nothing and
making something of your life sometimes
always monsters is it is a sequel but it
is also sort of the antithesis of that
first game right it is starting with
something and just the downward spiral
of what happens when something just goes
wrong that sounds super dark and tell me
a little bit about the story we won't
get into too many you know we won't get
any spoilers for you very story happy
finding but tell me just the very
beginning of who you are right so you
begin the game as an author and you're
about to start this book tour for the
big huge hit you just wrote but someone
has also accused you of not actually
writing that book so scandal is really
going on a tour right exactly exactly
you're going on a tour for the book that
some people are accusing you of not even
having written and so on that way you
bring your significant other you you
begin as a specific avatar but you have
whole range of people to choose from for
your significant others okay and so the
two of you are on that tour together
there's some hints that maybe you
actually stole the book from your spouse
your girlfriend boyfriends
exactly so obviously while you're on
this tour going in these different stops
go into these different cities the
things are gonna are gonna go downhill
and what are you doing like during these
actual moments you can like you know
walk and you can talk to people you can
form relationships but are you like
looking for trouble when you play so in
a way that's that's almost up to you
because it is very open-world as you're
going to each of these cities each one
is very different you have the one I
played was called Portsmouth which is
sort of a Seattle kind of take there are
things that are based on like something
like Phoenix Arizona or like New Orleans
so there are gonna feel a little
different but they're also all open to
the point where you can go into a store
and maybe buy some things you can pop to
the arcade and play a game I actually
played an arcade game
called like orphan inferno plate again
again yes where I was rescuing babies
from a burning building you gettin into
trouble did you anything bad I didn't do
anything bad
a homeless man approached me for some
money and I gave him a dollar so I felt
good about that so it sounds like you
really didn't go downward and your
spiral yet not yet but it was only the
first stop of the tour that's right so
by the end of it there there are
certainly many ways that your ending can
change so some people may have a very
dark time yeah it kind of like has a bit
of a like a requiem for a dream sound
like feel to where you're just like
watching everything go to [ __ ] really
and this is all set to a really dark and
somber visual and audio track right so
always sometimes monsters had a 16-bit
art style sometimes always monsters has
the same art style but whereas that
soundtrack was like uplifting and you
want to improve yourself this one is
like plotting and somber and yeah and
you and you know things aren't gonna go
so well would you say that you need to
play the original to like this game or
understand it or could you start on this
one no no you can hop right in to this
one so it may be like some in jokes
references for people who played the
first one but you could certainly jump
right in and have your story play out
because it's gonna play out differently
from someone else's anyway okay so you
just jump in and watch everything
crumble God well that was sometimes
always monsters and you can watch your
life crumble and get really depressed
about it sometime in 2016
you